When I write these movie analysis, I usually read the movie again.
Write down what I think is interesting
When I started watching Wang Jiawei’s "In the Mood for Love"
The first thing I wrote was
Actor characteristics of each shot
Not only created by the composition of the film
But through the details
This is the visual technology that filmmakers have used for decades.
My favorite example is the last shot of John Ford's masterpiece, "Searcher."
But rarely used so widely
With the development of the film, I recorded five points in my notebook.
And changed to six ⋯ seven ⋯ nine ⋯
I didn’t see the first mirror until the 12th minute.
No foreground obstacles
This mirror, the key is not to take the two main axes as the axis
Wait a minute, I am surpassing myself.
"In the Mood for Love" tells the story of two married couples
They rented a house in the old couple's home in Hong Kong in the 1960s.
The film focuses on a husband and wife husband Mr. Zhou
And Mrs. Chen, the wife of another couple
They gradually discovered that their spouse was cheating them.
Then the two innocent victims
Face this pain together
The film is deeply interested in the topic
At the same time, it is presented in colorful film photography.
Story timing jump
Because people will recall the story in memory
The audience is often confused about the transition between scenes
This prompts that there is a strong need to pay attention to the film.
But it also reflects the film making process
When Wang Jiawei and his staff started shooting, there was only a piecemeal idea.
Lasted 15 months
The script and personal scene are also impromptu
By the director and the actor
This is amazing because watching a movie
You will feel completely controlled
In the visual and emotional aspects, "In the Mood for Love" is completely consistent.
This movie is so independent that there are only a few locations
Shooting from the same angle
Let you experience the cycle of returning to the same thing again and again
This technique does not sluggish or repeat and is not a fixed background
What is actually changing in the movie - the inner life of the two main lines
In most cases, these inner lives are silent explorations.
Real action through gestures and contact
By limiting the language, Wang Jiawei responded to the restrictions of action
Mr. Zhou and Mrs. Chen, bothering the 1960s
They have been threatened by rumors
a surveillance from homeowners and the entire community
This is why everything is a double framework
By placing objects in the foreground, the director can enhance the feeling of the character.
Observed by us
Repeated observations to see our desire for others and the desire of others for us
This is the theme of "In the Mood for Love"
I think the most extraordinary element in the movie is what I just introduced.
The two protagonists admit each other: their spouse is kicking
Their goal is not to face this situation but to understand
How does this happen?
So we saw this incredible scene and they re-enacted their spouse
Each of them tries to embody the spouse of the other party and is guided by the other party.
They think that the spouse will really do this or not
This becomes very complicated and an illegitimate interaction
Although this film only focuses on Mr. Zhou and Mrs. Chen.
Even the spouse who never showed up
But we always know that there are four people involved here, not just two people.
But this is not four real people. It is two people and two imaginations.
Think about the requirements for Zhou and Chen in the temptation scene.
In order to understand what happened, they all tried to seduce each other.
In the form of the other’s spouse
It must be done from the beginning because the matter itself means
No matter whether it is Zhou or Chen, they can no longer violate the desire they want to recreate.
You can describe this behavior as masochistic
And Wang Jiawei makes us feel this when they
Are themselves or each other’s spouse
Before reality, we tend to be only one-sided interpretation
Or maybe the current unreal is like a shock
But they constantly guide each other so they can build a fantasy in it.
They control their betrayal
And never made them love each other, Mr. Zhou and Mrs. Chen.
Infinite delay, they must see the moment of truth
Still staying in their fantasy
This is a tragic and distorted state of affairs and Wang Jiawei said if
Liang Chaowei and Maggie Cheung are not so beautiful actors.
Their darkness and fantasy are obvious
Of course they can't keep it forever and in the scene where Mr. Zhou finally admits his love for Mrs. Chen.
Most of the fantasies are shattered
As he said they are like their spouse means something they have been refusing to see.
Their shortcoming is that they are no longer the object of the spouse’s love but rush into consciousness.
Like the waves
However, they did not take action
They can only let this cruel truth swell
For life, for the future, Mr. Zhou and Mrs. Chen are not willing to miss the relationship.
That's why the last movie showed us that they missed each other twice.
Just missing the other party is only the possibility of connection, not the connection itself
Is the thing that supports them now.
Everyone is living in the framework of fantasy
Sometimes the frame is made by us and sometimes made by others
Sometimes we need to believe that what we do is created by others
But there is no way to get rid of the framework anyway.
When the fantasy rupture completely collapses, it is trauma
Like living temporarily in the storm
Wang Jiawei’s "In the Mood for Love" is a gorgeous quiet and painful exploration of what will happen at that time.
You create a false fantasy for yourself
When it's just to stop you from avoiding the pain of creating it
And this movie is so heartbreaking because of this distortion
It’s too common for everyone
Thank you very much for watching, I hope you like it.
God, I love this movie.
If you think The Nerdwriter is something you didn't see anywhere else on YouTube.
And you want to help support it and help me continue to spend time and effort to make such a video.
You can go to my Patreon page which will be great, you are all great
Every little thing will help, so you can click here for just $1.
Thanks again, if you haven't subscribed yet, don't forget to subscribe.
Get all the videos and keep focusing on some really cool content
Some cool collaborations are coming soon there are more videos here